[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain an american comedy film
called blank check spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
in the opening scene we are introduced
to 11 year old preston waters he lives
with his parents and two elder brothers
who always trouble him recently they
have taken over a part of preston's room
to store a computer system for their
small business
preston's father fred supports his older
sons and urges the youngest one to
compromise preston is mad because he
always gets the short end of the stick
later he goes to an amusement park for
his friend butch's birthday party since
his father only gave him ten dollars to
have fun he cannot join his friends on
the roller coaster rides instead he is
stuck on the lame merry-go-round the
kids make fun of him for not having
enough money preston's family is not
poor but his father is passionate about
teaching his kids how to handle and save
money hence he has never had the best of
anything during breakfast the next
morning preston's older brothers leave
to go to a baseball game he wants to
join them but he doesn't have money for
the tickets fred explains to him that
saving is important if he wants to have
fun but the kid argues that he cannot
save when he doesn't earn his mother
hands him an envelope that is an early
birthday present from his grandmother
inside is a blank check which preston
thinks is useless because it has no
amount written on it his father fills
the check in with 11
because he thinks it's an appropriate
amount to be gifted to a kid when
preston whines about it being too little
fred claims that with proper interest
the money can grow to a million dollars
in no time this movie was obviously made
in the 90s preston checks the theory on
the internet and finds out his 11 will
take at least 300 000 years to grow into
a million after looking at that number
he accepts the fact that he will not be
a millionaire anytime soon still he
wishes to have his own house and a lot
of money by tomorrow and goes to sleep
elsewhere quigley is a con artist who
has just escaped from jail on a rainy
night he goes to an abandoned building
where he had hidden a million dollars
prior to his imprisonment he plans to
use the money to buy a new identity for
himself however since the bills are
marked consecutively the fbi can track
them back to him easily he thinks of a
plan and goes to meet the president of a
bank named biderman who also used to be
his partner in the money laundering
business quigley wants him to exchange
randomly marked bills in turn for the
serially marked million dollars that he
has this way the fbi wouldn't be
suspicious even if they find out about
his purchases spiderman is reluctant
because he doesn't want to get into the
laundry business again but quigley
threatens to kill his family if he
doesn't help him
that'll do it when biterman obliges he
is told to hand the money to a man named
juice the next day at the same time
preston comes to the bank to cash in his
11
and open a bank account he is received
by a beautiful bank teller shea she
gently tells him that he needs to have a
minimum deposit of 200
preston promises to come back in when he
earns that much and leaves outside his
friend butch snatches the check and runs
away while trying to catch him preston
ends up behind quigley's car and his
bicycle is crushed by it quigley is
bound to pay for the bike but before he
can write in a mouth on the check he
sees a police car nearby he hands the
kid the blank check and drives away
immediately upon reaching home fred
scolds preston because of his broken
bicycle he gets grounded for a week but
doesn't tell his parents about the
accident or the blank check at night he
amounts the check to a million dollars
and writes a random name on it the very
next day he goes to the bank to cash it
however the bank teller thinks that he
is joking and brings him to president
biderman since the check has quigly
signature on it spiderman thinks that
the kid is juice the middleman between
him and quigly preston thinks the idea
is stupid and is about to walk away but
spiderman stops him to the kid's
surprise he brings out bundles of money
from the safe and fills his bag with
them while running away with the money
preston bumps into the real juice but
the man thinks he's just a random kid
and lets him get away he meets spiderman
and introduces himself as quigley's
henchman spiderman quickly realizes his
blunder and runs outside to look for
preston but by then he is long gone
since the money is illegal they cannot
ask the police for help as soon as
preston reaches home he looks for houses
on sale in his neighborhood he finds the
one he is looking for and calls the
realtor following that he talks to her
using the computer's robotic voice and
buys the house for three hundred
thousand dollars yep definitely the 90s
when asked about his name preston looks
at the computer and says macintosh he is
overjoyed to have finally gotten
everything that he wants in life when
quigley finds out that his money is
missing he fumes in anger at first he
insists that it was biterman's fault but
then he remembers the blank check he
gave to the kid with the broken bicycle
the three of them decide to visit the
general places where kids go to find the
one who stole their money in the
meantime preston buys a limo for himself
and asks the driver to pick him up from
his house he sneaks out through the
window and meets the driver henry
initially henry believes the kid is
trying to play a prank on him but upon
being handed the money he apologizes and
sits him in the vehicle preston says
that the car belongs to mcintosh a
millionaire businessman he claims to be
an employee who works for mcintosh so
that no one will doubt his story henry
doesn't question him and takes him to
every mall in town at his request they
buy clothes tvs toys video games and
many more things to fill his new house
preston also buys a bucket full of ice
cream something his parents would never
allow him to do he even gives henry an
expensive watch as a present for
accompanying him to the malls while
returning home that night he bumps into
the bank teller shea she remembers him
as the 200 kid preston says that he has
earned some money and is soon coming to
meet her at the bank preston's gonna be
pimping in no time after they go their
separate ways we see shea secretly
meeting a man and telling him everything
about her workplace it is revealed that
she is a secret fbi agent who is on a
mission to catch the money launderers
working in the bank the next morning
fred is about to drive to work but their
driveway is blocked by several vehicles
transferring toys furniture and tvs into
another house in the neighborhood he
goes to check what the fuss is all about
and finds his youngest son ordering
people around when fred asks him what is
going on he says that he has started to
work for macintosh their new neighbor
who is moving in today fred doesn't want
his son to work for a stranger but
preston convinces him that mcintosh is a
good man he even orders the workers to
clear the path for his father's car fred
is stunned to see the kind of authority
preston has over them when the house is
finally done it has a race track several
balloon houses a built-in video game
system preston's personal office and a
swimming pool with a slide that connects
to the office meanwhile quigley biderman
and juice go around amusement parks
looking for the kid their only clue is a
blurry picture taken by the surveillance
camera in the bank the word about a
wealthy man moving into the neighborhood
goes around and even shay hears about
macintosh because of his unconditional
wealth and the way he spends it she
suspects him to be part of a criminal
organization one day she goes to meet
him in the house and finds preston
instead when asked about macintosh
preston says he is in a meeting and is
on a tight schedule for the next month
or so shea is about to leave when
preston asks her out on a professional
date she hesitates initially but agrees
to go when he lies about being
macintosh's financial manager later he
asks the driver henry for advice since
henry has dated more women than him
according to henry women like chiseled
men with money they prepare for the date
by exercising daily with time henry
becomes his best friend as they play eat
and have fun together preston's family
still thinks he's working for mcintosh
still fred doesn't allow him to go out
on a date at night preston slyly
whispers that he was about to show
fred's work proposal to macintosh
sensing that his son's relationship with
a millionaire might help him fred lets
preston do anything he wants at night he
and shea go to a fancy restaurant for
dinner he gives her a necklace as a
present but claims that it is from
macintosh similarly he also asks her
questions about her dating preferences
while insisting he was told by macintosh
to ask them later they go to a water
fountain and play however the fun ends
when quigley and his group bump into
them preston asks shay to race him to
the limo and drives away before they can
catch him before separating he invites
her to his and macintosh's birthday
party on the weekend upon finding out
that macintosh will be present at the
party shay agrees to come the next day
preston hires a party planner who
charges him a ten thousand dollar
deposit she wants to plan a fancy dinner
and make a lot of profit by ripping him
off later henry goes out with his
friends and preston is left all alone in
the house with nothing to do he goes to
the park to reminisce about his old life
at the same time quigley and his group
also arrive at the park looking for him
they spot him but preston cycles away
immediately a chase ensues between them
but the trio has to stop when their car
crashes on top of another car spiderman
comments that stealing another million
dollars would be easier than chasing
this kid just when they're about to give
up they hit the jackpot and find
preston's friend butch they hold him on
the edge of the roof of a building and
make him reveal preston's name and
address that night is also the night of
the birthday party as all the
preparations take place in the mansion
preston's brothers call shea a gold
digger convinced that she is hanging out
with him for macintosh's money shay may
be a gold digger but preston is a miner
this upsets preston and he asks henry
for his expert advice he also affirms
that some people are only nice to him
because of his money they finally go to
the party but preston isn't allowed to
touch his own present because the
security guard is waiting for macintosh
to open them he also finds the food
awful because he was expecting to get
pizza and ice cream somewhere else shea
and her team have found out that
macintosh has no past records which
means he is a criminal trying to create
a new identity they plan to catch the
man and arrest him tonight the party
planner gives preston a bill of a
hundred thousand dollars when he returns
to his office to check his account he
realizes that he has spent all of his
million dollars in only six days now he
only has a little over three hundred
dollars left he goes outside and tells
the planner that macintosh is missing
which means she will not get paid the
woman creates a scene and asks everyone
to go home because the party is over
soon everyone takes their presents and
returns home when preston is alone in
the living room quigley and his team
arrive at the house asking him for his
money a scared preston tells them the
truth but the adults refuse to believe
he spent all million dollars in less
than a week spiderman suggests quigly
steal macintosh's identity since he is
non-existent anyway they like the idea
but the only problem is preston who
might reveal the truth to anybody
hearing this preston runs outside and is
followed by the three they get into a
chase in the house but since preston
knows every corner of it he outsmarts
them the childish addition to the house
like the slide through his office and
the built-in video game system comes in
handy still in the end quigley manages
to catch him right then the fbi
surrounds the house and asks them to
leave the kid alone they arrest all
three of them for fraud money laundering
and theft quigley is assumed to be
macintosh hence preston is let free
without interrogation the kid finds out
shea is an fbi agent and is sad that she
cannot be his girlfriend shay kisses him
and asks him to meet her in 10 years
grooming kids was cool in the 90s on
walking outside preston meets henry who
had gone to get ice cream since they
cannot work together again they wish
each other farewell in the last scene
preston walks home with his father to
see that his family has made a surprise
birthday cake for him when asked to make
a wish he realizes that he already has
everything he wants in life his family
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching